Thomas you've you've had a briefing with
some fairly sobering thoughts behind it
yes indeed I've got a document here
which underpins the government's science
the science behind its strategy and it
really does make some really sobering
reading actually : and this is from the
Imperial College kovat 19 response team
they're the ones who've been advising
the government on this as I say and they
say that we are in for the long haul
here they talking about how they have
changed their minds in the last few days
based on what is happening in Italy they
also say demand here early in the
outbreak is proving to be twice as high
on the hospitals than they had been
anticipating with a high number of
patients being admitted to intensive
care and a high proportion of those
dying so they have redone the maths
they're looking again at what is likely
to happen here in the UK and I have to
tell you : that they are talking about
even with the kind of measures that were
hearing about today that they're
predicting that they might reduce the
peak critical care demand by two thirds
and half the number of deaths but even
with this optimal mitigation scenario
you're still looking at an Eightfold
higher peak demand on critical care beds
over and above the available surge
capacity in the UK they're talking that
even in the most favorable scenario
there would be in the order of two
hundred and fifty thousand deaths in the
UK and based on that strategy now what
they're saying that the only possible
conclusion is that epidemic suppression
is the only viable strategy at this time
to in effect stop the virus circulating
that would have to go on until a vaccine
was developed in 12 to 18 month time and
that the social and economic effects of
those measures to achieve that policy
goal will be profound it's hard to
underestimate
the significance of this document
you